county commissioners are looking to
crack down on the exotic rental car
industry recent crashes involving exotic
rentals are prompting them to maybe
possibly change and have some new
ordinances joe moeller was at today's
commissioner's meeting he is live near
twain and dean martin with what happened
today joe
denise well people come here to las
vegas and they want to do something fun
so they decide hey why not rent an
exotic car or even one of these
slingshots that we all see around town
now county commissioners want to see
what they can do to bring down the
amount of crashes involving these
rentals
i don't know how you regulate stupid
from speeding to impairment county
commissioners are looking at how and if
they can regulate the exotic rental car
industry 8 to 12 percent of the clark
county fatals crashes involve a luxury
rented vehicle a string of recent
crashes is what is prompting the action
the first step was andrew bennett from
the nevada office of traffic safety
sharing data about the industry he says
95 percent of those exotic rental
crashes involve impairment speed and
impairment were extremely prevalent in
these luxury and exotic rental
fatalities and so you know looking at
the possibilities of
ignition interlock is a program that
we've had in our state to reduce
impaired driving there is an opportunity
to do speed monitoring he says there
needs to be a more clear definition of
what an exotic luxury or auto cycle
rental is an auto cycle being these
popular sling shots one was involved in
a recent double fatal in red rock being
able to vet the companies that do this
first is kind of our biggest issue tony
ketchings is the general manager at
royalty exotic cars put the keys in the
hand of a owner of an exotic car company
they should be able to tell you
everything in the vehicle without even
being close to it he says companies need
to be regulated and so do the customers
we're pushing for
more regulation in the industry to be
able to say
yes these people are properly vetted to
rent a car to drive a car that's 650 700
800 horsepower
back out here live next the county will
take a look at the data they saw today
to see if they can implement more
regulation with a new ordinance to
hopefully keep everybody out of the
roads safer reporting live joe mohler
live local now